there what may be however
one way that it could be worth it and
that is if joe manchin agrees to kill
the filibuster
so that democrats can pass the john
lewis voting rights act
and the reason that piece of legislation
is so dang important
is because of the new report we got this
week
according to a new report from cnn
you have
multiple republican-controlled states
out there including some who have
already passed
restrictive voting measures this year
that already have a full slate of
legislation with even more
restrictions
heading our way in 2022
let me read this
lawmakers in four states already have
pre-filed at least 13 bills for the 2022
legislative sessions that would make it
harder to cast a ballot that is of
course according to the brennan center
for justice
in five states six pre-filed bills would
allow audits or reviews of election
results as former president donald trump
and his allies continue to baselessly
attribute his 2020 loss to election
fraud
in addition
some 88 restrictive bills that were
introduced but failed to become law in
nine states this year are expected to
carry over into legislative sessions set
to begin early next year and let's not
forget that so far in 2021
19 states passed 34
restrictive voting bills
because this is what they do
because this is the only way that
republicans can win
they can't win on the issues
they can't win on economics they can't
win on policy they can't win on populism
i know trump did in 2016 but technically
lost the
popular vote
so what do they do
they do two things they resort to
culture war issues which they've been
fairly successful with this year and of
course voter
suppression keep just enough people out
of the way
and we might be able to have a victory
drum up even more support from our
crazed base
with these culture war issues by talking
about critical race theory and
transgender athletes
and we might be able to eke out a
victory
and of course they're helped along the
way with gerrymandering which is going
to play a huge
role in the 2022 elections
the only x factor out there right now is
how many people died from kovid that
would vote for republicans
according to the numbers we're seeing
right now a lot
so
they're going to have to contend with
that
continuing to push anti-mask and
anti-vax viewpoints isn't going to work
out so well for them electorally
so of course they have to push these
restrictive voting bills
and as i said
one of the worst parts of this is some
of these are in states that have already
passed
restrictive voting measures this year
florida and georgia are the top two
georgia is still trying to go even
further
according to this new report
by
further limiting drop boxes further
limiting
collection of ballots
and of course cutting down on the number
of polling places
in a given
county
florida again i mentioned this earlier
this week they want to create a new five
million dollar office whose job it is to
go around and find voter fraud
which
i mean does exist to a small degree
certainly not in
in enough numbers to sway an election
and of course most the cases we're
finding here in florida are
republicans so that's probably not going
to work out very well for them but
that's what they're doing and they're
doing it because they can't win on the
issues
they can't win talking to normal people
so they shut them out
they get them out of the system get them
off the voting rules by any means
necessary
because that is their only path to
victory
they've been hugely successful with it
in the past
and most of these places where these
bills are being proposed
there's not enough opposition
to prevent them from becoming law before
the 2022 election